fitness ernährung schönheits op ist
alles dreht sich derzeit um den körper
wir sprechen aber nicht über den
optimierten körper sondern über den der
aus der norm fällt ja wir sprechen mit
menschen die anders aussehen und
deswegen auffallen und fahren normal was
ist das eigentlich warum wollen wir alle
gerne normal sein und trotzdem irgendwie
speziell unser ambivalentes verhältnis
zur normalität jetzt in der sternstunde
der nacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
normal
schon das wort verursacht gänsehaut und
was hat dieser begriff nicht schon alles
erdulden müssen
die normale ehe die normale familie
die normale gesellschaft
normal ist alles was nicht aneckt stört
oder außerhalb des mainstreams steht
nur wer definiert das und was passiert
mit abnormalen das mehrheitsfähig wird
gemäss statistischer definition bedeutet
normal
das durchschnittliche verhalten der
mehrheit in der soziologie umschreibt
der begriff das selbstverständliche in
einer gesellschaft das nicht mehr
erklärt werden muss
es wird klar das einzige normale am
begriff normal ist dass er stets für
etwas anderes steht
wenn also ein gesellschaftliches
phänomen eine gewisse größe erreicht hat
gilt es somit als normal
heute ist normal das 16,7 prozent der
schweizer kinder adipös sind ebenso
normal ein viertel der 25 bis 34
jährigen ist tätowiert somit auch normal
einer von 16 also 6,25 prozent der
menschen in der schweiz sind körperlich
stark behindert oder macht die
gesellschaft sie behindert ja und ich
begrüße ganz herzlich unseren ersten
gast nämlich raul krauthausen ist
blogger ist moderator er ist buchautor
und vorstandsvorsitzender der sozial
hält in einer organisation die sich auf
inklusion spezialisiert hat ganz
herzlich willkommen hier hält
daher krauthausen sie sagen dass
behinderte menschen sehr oft in
talkshows eingeladen werden als eine art
alibi übung nämlich um den nicht
behinderten menschen ein gutes gefühl zu
geben
was muss heute abend hier passieren
damit dass hier keine übung wird über
andere dinge zu reden als über die
tatsache dass ich im rollstuhl sitze
vielleicht auch versuchen herauszufinden
was mein charakter ausmacht meine
interessen meine träume meine ziele
meine leidenschaften so dass dann die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer auch die
erlaubnis haben zu sagen aha krauthausen
dass es ein charakter schwein den würde
ich ungerne zum gipfeltreffen oder das
gegenteil wenn sie gerne hier und da das
charakter schwein mehr ich hab manchmal
schon die beobachtungen der so große
berührungsängste gegenüber menschen mit
behinderung also zb mit mir gibt dass
sie daneben sich mit ihrer kritik oder
vielleicht auch mit der besagten mit der
andere meinung eher zurückhaltend
die denken ach das arme hascherl so zum
rollstuhl oder traurig müssten jährlich
was zu sagen
mich interessiert ja wirklich auch sehr
ihre expertise eben bei diesen
sozialhelden dieses inklusions thema als
erste frage habe ich mir ausgedacht ich
wüsste eines gerne mal von ihnen wie sie
den begriff normal definieren was heißt
das für sie also ich fange sie dem ein
spieler ganz interessant dass da gesagt
wurde dass das einzig beständige import
normal ist die ständige veränderung und
wenn wir kinder beobachten oder ich
beobachte auch täglich kinder weil sie
nicht beobachten und dann natürlich
neugierig sind und dann zu ihren eltern
frauen zu fragen guck mal papa warum
seid ihr denn so aus oder gucken wir mal
was hat denn der un werde ich dann mit
den kindern aber direkt ins gespräch
komme manchmal weil sie dann selber ihre
neugier direkt an mich richten oder weil
die situation leider erlaubt dass wir
miteinander reden
ich bin ich der fried der sollten wir
jedes kind ein spricht sondern einfach
denn im gespräch sich oft ergibt dass
kinder natürlich neugierig sind und das
total okay ist aber nach spätestens 23
minuten an die das als das neue normal
dann praktisch verinnerlicht und wenn
sie denken mich wieder sehen dann
erzählen sie mir wo sie gerade herkommt
oder wo sie hingehen und was bleibt ihr
lieblingseis und sind eben nicht mehr
unsicher und neugierig warum denn der
mann zu klein ist ich empfinde das
selber immer wieder aus einem ganz
schwierigen grad dieses einerseits
neugierig sein und sie haben gerade
gesagt sie werden angeguckt angestarrt
und vielleicht sich eine gesunde neugier
auch für das andere für die differenz zu
bewahren und gleichzeitig platz war
juristisch zu sein ja wie können wir das
lernen und so verläuft diese grenze dass
ich ganz gerne dann so als skript gebe
bei der journalistinnen und journalisten
mit unserem projekt leitmedien ja auch
egal wie eben man über menschen mit
behinderung zum beispiel berichtet ist
dass wir sagen
versuchen sie die behinderung zu
begreifen wie eine haarfarbe
also macht jemand trotz seiner blonden
haare etwas oder mit den blonden haaren
und wenn wir die behinderungen
gleichsetzen würden wieder haarfarbe
dann wäre das vielleicht gar nicht mehr
so relevant
also wenn wir uns jetzt menschen
kennenlernen würden zum ersten mal und
sie sind vielleicht normal typisch dann
würde mich natürlich nicht interessieren
wie sie sich in ihrem geschlecht spielen
oder ob sie homo oder heterosexuell sind
sondern ich würde dann vielleicht als
einstiegsfrage fragen wo kommen sie
gerade
wie sind sie zum beruf der moderator in
gekommen und ich würde mir wünschen dass
die leute nicht wenn sie mir begegnen
als allererstes die frage im kopf haben
wo gott warum ist denn der mann so klein
warum sitzen im rollstuhl ab der
schmerzen tut das weh leidet er sodann
überhaupt die frage haben wo kommt er
her wie lebt er eigentlich in berlin
was was hat ja eigentlich studiert hat
er studiert
solche fragen nicht mehr gestellt werden
ist das auch der grund warum sie ihren
eigenen talk sendungen die heißt
facebook fest mit krauthausen ihres
vorgestellt werden aus der mann mit der
mütze und eben nicht zum beispiel der
moderator im rollstuhl
ja wobei ich mir mal gesagt habe ich
möchte also ich höre dann mit dem beruf
das erklärt das sage ich auch wenn die
leute sagen der mann mit der mütze und
nicht der meinung rollstuhl dann habe
ich für nichts und persönliche messlatte
wenn ich dann nur noch mit der man mir
damit so angesprochen werden oder er
eingeführt werde
dann habe ich meinen job erledigt und
dann kann ich aufhören in rente gehen
haben die folien gerade ihr eigenes
projekt oder eines ihrer ganz vielen
projekte erwähnten machen ja so viele
projekte machen die so hervorragend dass
sie dieses jahr auch den grimme online
award erhalten haben eben für ihre blogs
für ganz verschiedene dinge und dieses
projekt leitmedien mit schwachem de
schult eben journalistinnen und
journalisten darin in einer inklusiven
art und weise über behinderte menschen
zum beispiel zu berichten also dazu
gehört dass man eben nicht sagt du bist
ein opfer von irgendetwas und eben auch
nicht zb sie leiden an
glasknochenkrankheit sondern wenn schon
sie haben auf knochen und selbst das
wäre wahrscheinlich etwas was man gar
nicht erwähnen müsste weil der mann sich
weiter mit mir beschäftigt oder mit der
arbeit die wir nicht alleine
das team machen sind die themen
inklusion barriere teilhabe
selbstbestimmung von menschen mit
behinderung und dann ist es sogar
irrelevant was meine diagnose ist also
fast ist es sich so zum rollstuhl dass
china das kann man im kamerabild
wahrscheinlich besonders gut erkennen
und dann ist es relativ egal dass meine
diagnose ausmacht weil offensichtlich
bin ich expertin eigene sache und ob ich
jetzt glasknochen querschnittslähmung
oder muskelschwund habe spielt in dem
moment keine rolle bei gegeben sind die
gleichen
und es befriedigt er einen voyeurismus
den voyeurismus ende des journalisten
oder der zuschauer werden oder des
zuschauers wo man ich fest davon
überzeugt bin auch bei der in der
journalisten habe journalistischen
arbeit hinterher auch teilweise tätig
bin dass man den zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern auch nicht alles erklären
muss also man kann das publikum auch
fragen zurücklassen
und wenn es sie denn wirklich brennend
interessiert ob er krauthausen
glasmacher irgendwas ganz anderes dann
können sie das auch in der suchmaschine
iris matthey uns herausfinden
aber ich denke nicht dass wir gegen top
league kommt es zu einfach machen
sollten immer dinge zu erklären ich
bekomme sehr oft von journalistinnen die
antwort na ja aber wir müssen das den
zuschauern erklären
dieses klassische wir müssen sie
mitnehmen abholen und wieder freilassen
dass er in journalismus gerne gesagt wo
ich denke weiter verkaufen wir auch das
publikum zu dumm
also das publikum ist schlauer als wir
glauben ich würde ihnen ja ganz gerne
eine geschichte erzählen die wir gerade
in den sinn kommt ich bin 13 gut aus
einer s bahnstation ausgestiegen und mir
begegnete eine familie vierköpfige
familie zwei kinder zwei eltern und dann
brachte der junge papa warum ist denn
der mann so klein und der vater
antwortete und das ist wirklich spannend
was der vater geantwortet hat er
antwortete der mann ist aus dem gleichen
grund so klein warum du ein junge und
ein mädchen ist
und das war bisher in meinem ganzen
38-jährigen leben die beste antwort die
je von einem erwachsenen gehört habe die
politisch korrekt kindgerecht erklärt
und auch noch biologisch korrekt ist mit
den genen zu tun haben alles mit ihm
gehen zu tun hat und man hat es ja sagen
wir mal den den komplexen sachverhalt
der wirklich komplexen so reduziert dass
das kind der abteilung frage wer hat das
wünsche ich mir mehr als
selbstverständlichkeit
sie haben ihrem buch das sie geschrieben
haben einen titel gegeben der natürlich
für sich spricht und frauen für ihren
charme und ihren witz spricht das heißt
nämlich dachdecker wollte ich eh nicht
werden
und dieses buch liest sich ja auch
tatsächlich sehr witzig gewisse stellen
sind aber auch extrem bedrückend sie
beschreiben zum beispiel sie nach hause
gehen nach einer party und auf dem
nachhauseweg von zwei personen quasi
blöd angemacht werden die greifen ihn
einfach in den schritt also das sind zu
stellen wo man das buch ist fast west
tag legen muss
worauf ich hinaus will ist dieser sagen
wir mal sehr sehr positive blick auf die
welt den sie haben gibt es da nicht auch
so etwas wie ein glücks imperativ in
unserer gesellschaft der mama schwierig
ist dass wir denken alle menschen müssen
immer alles was ihnen widerfährt auch
noch positiv wenden
obwohl manche dinge ja auch wenn wir mal
ganz platz sagen einfach scheiße sind zu
dem buchtitel würde ich gerne noch eine
sache sagen
das buch heißt ja dachte da wollte ich
ähnlich werden ein leben aus dem
rollstuhl perspektive und ich habe sehr
lange mit dem verlag darüber gesprochen
ob er dieses ein leben aus der rollstuhl
perspektive nicht weglassen können weil
man sieht ja auf dem cover dass ich im
rollstuhl sitze und mannheim die
gelackten habe wir müssen das machen
weil da kann man es nämlich in einem
online buchhandel besser suchen
bilder kann man nicht suchen und das war
auch eine debatte die wir da geführt
haben der zu jeder frage mit dem mit dem
thema glück
ich kenne sehr viele menschen mit
behinderung und da würde ich mich zu mit
einschließen die humor als eine
überlebensstrategie für sich entdeckt
haben um die unsicherheit der
nichtbehinderten mehrheit gesellschaft
mit humor irgendwie zu überspielen und
zu überbrücken für diesen moment wo
dieses diesen berühmten ort moment
dieser dieser rosa elefanten brauchen
die liebe thematisiert und diese stille
oder glauben haid liegen wir alle und
ich kann für mich die strategie
entwickelt habe oft witz zu machen
meistens auf meine kosten um die
situation zu entspannen und auch
aufzulockern und das hat jemand
irgendwann den ruf gegeben dass sich ein
clown bin dass ich in witziger mensch
bin und er sich ja irgendwie so fröhlich
sei aber es gibt natürlich auch momente
wie bei jedem anderen auch ruhig mal
traurig bin oder nachdenklich gedanken
habe wir werden noch viel von ihnen
lernen heute da bin ich mir ganz sicher
ganz herzlichen dank für diese erste
einschätzung sie haben sozusagen von
kindesbeinen an gelernt mit schwierigen
momenten umzugehen auch mit der
ungerechtigkeit dieser welt manchmal
ungewöhnliche aber auch mit schönem
selbstverständlich aber jetzt trifft es
an der bar eine person für die sich über
nacht das leben komplett verändert hat
ja genau bei mir sitzt marcel mathis sie
haben 2005 bei einem brand in ihrer
wohnung heftige verbrennungen erlitten
am ganzen körper und dabei auch ihr
gesicht verloren könnte man sagen das
ist 13 jahre her
können sie sich noch erinnern was in
dieser nacht passiert ist
da hat jeder mensch als rede
jede verletzung dieser intensiv ist da
geht es wie ein ausschalter david hörten
die systeme der gefahr ist zu diesem
system entwickelt auch benötigt werden
die ressourcen benötigen um zu
auch nicht zum laichen aus diesem grund
kann ich nicht sagen auszugehen in
seiffen klaus gehen wollen ist sie haben
vieles vergessen lagen danach auch
längere zeit im koma nicht interessiert
alle aufgewacht sind und zum ersten mal
in berührung gekommen sind mit ihrem
körper mit der verbrennung
was ist da in ihnen passiert so versieht
das ist ja das ist ja nicht man hat ja
in dieser situation nicht die
möglichkeit zu sagen erzählte etwas
nicht schönes passiert das ist etwas in
die hosen gegangen
es ist etwas schlimmes passiert da gibt
es nicht groß die möglichkeit zu
entscheiden will ich als diese situation
annehmen oder nicht und hatte augen
falls drei möglichkeiten entweder ich
nehme sie an wie ich jetzt was ist die
antwort ja und die variante zwei ist ich
nehme sie an
aber da kann auf der anderen seite mit
dieser situation nicht der genauso ich
fühle mich zu haben als sie die ganze
zeit eingesperrt ich nicht mehr unter
die welt tragen ich nicht nicht mehr
nach draußen
trotzdem noch überhaupt nicht mehr die
gleiche das kanadische western oder die
gleiche freiheit genossen hat weil er
sich nicht getraut nach 13 sekunden
die letzte variante das werden eventuell
die schlimmste wenn man überhaupt nicht
wenn wir diese situation zuge kommt ja
überhaupt nicht mehr die kraft hat er
hat dann hat man auch nicht die kraft
für die und heilung für die generelle
heilung dann wäre man dann werden auch
die ärzte machtlos gegenüber dieser
situation bei ihnen ist das anders sie
gehen in die öffentlichkeit
mich interessiert sie hatten ja mehrere
operationen dann auch wie lange hat das
gedauert bis sie bis sich ihr gesicht
als ihr eigenes wieder angeführt hat
oder fühlte sich heute noch verändern
auf eine art und weise
also ich weiß dass mein gesicht nicht
mehr dem entspricht wie es früher
ausgesehen hat das ist eine situation
die kann ich nicht von ihr weg schicken
da kann die dinge
in der geschenke noch so guten job mache
also ich werde nie mehr so ein gesicht
bekommen ich mal gekauft habe um seine
nach verlusten und wegen sich der
meinung ist ich gehe jetzt ihre vision
zu viele operation hinter mir und so
soundsoviele operation irgendwie ergehen
lassen ja ich kann nie zum auto gehen
als um ein netz und content ein wunsch
zeitfressenden da müssen die aussagen
erlaubt ist hier und hier in
medizinischen möglichkeiten und hier
sind die uns medizinisch die hände
gebunden weil anatomie von einem gesicht
kräfte nicht mehr die gleiche
voraussetzung hat wieder sein ein
gesunder körper hat zwar alles was uns
kann und das ganze gewese ich mir vorher
müssen und da muss man sich auch an
geschenken entscheidungen komme ja und
da im unterricht kommt dann hat die
orion die ich vorher schon gedanken in
unserem vorgespräch hat mich am meisten
überrascht dass sie gesagt haben dieser
umfang der hat ihr leben bereichert ja
das ist so
ich meine sie das war als ich sage mal
auch ich finde ich kann vom licht
erhalten dass vor der verletzung nicht
nicht an in welchen anderen leute
vielleicht einmal lustig gemacht habe
oder und werden mal eine verletzung
gerissen habe
ich bin nicht so zögerlich von mir zu
erhalten
ich wäre nicht so gewesen also nicht
wahr dass ich sehe das als bereicherung
an dass ich heute die möglichkeit habe
die these diesem motto von einem
verletzten auseinandersetzen zu müssen
und auch die variante aus gesunden
menschen in zügen und auch abschätzen zu
können wie er ihr gegenüber anderen
leute urteil keine kenntnisse zu hause
ja wort geben
es heißt nicht real oder dass die
anlagen ist die situation ein urteil zu
bilden oder gar keine möglichkeit dazu
habe ja einfach aufgrund des äußeren
auch also ja wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe ist mit dieser äußeren
veränderung auch eine innere verwandlung
veränderungen einher gegangen und sie
sehen jetzigen wie die welt die menschen
anders und haben auch andere grundwerte
könnte man sagen ja weil durch diese
verletzungen haben sich auch
festgestellt dass nicht nur das äußere
eben das optische bild relevant ist
sondern dass auch vieles was wir nicht
alles nur mit händen greifen können oder
was wir aus schulden oder hübsch
definieren wichtig ist ja aber diese
bereicherung wie sie sagen geht nicht so
weit das ist sogar sagen würden
angenommen es gäbe medizinische wunder
ich möchte das alte gesicht nicht mehr
zurück weil ich sage jetzt einstellung
zu seiner leistung knapp 50 oder etwas
da muss unsere würde auch bewusst sein
was ist weiter ziehen ist kaum
vielleicht sich die wände ziehen kann
sich weiter entwickeln sich immer auch
so sein
die hand gebraucht auch ihre zeit um
alle fälle diese genesung zu bekommen
und auf die offenbar ein alter mit der
medizin alles noch stellt ja das ist die
andere seite oder wenn sie in der
öffentlichkeit unterwegs sind ihm
zugedachten straßen dann erstarren die
leute die leute gehen auf distanz
verletzt sie das heute noch 13 jahre
nach dem umfang also wenn ich habe das
zu beginn nie verletzt also eine extra
die war das anders die hat also immer
etwas nützen können es gehe nun ihr habt
dass er etwas gestört oder sie hatte
sehr zur kenntnis genommen werden und
das ist sage ich nicht nur früher
sondern gesagt ich sage das auch obwohl
ich nicht verletzt war
wie gehen sie eigentlich mit
leid um das ist überhaupt nichts was ich
benötige noch eine letzte frage die mich
interessiert ist es gibt ja verletzungen
die sieht man auf anhieb so etwas wie
ihre verbrennung dann gibt es innere
verletzungen seelische vielleicht ein
missbrauch in der kindheit
was ist für sie schlimmer dass man etwas
permanent sieht und alle anderen ein
problem kennen das ein sehr nahe
betrifft also sorge sicher es gibt viele
leute die depression haben andere
mentale verletzung die man nicht mit
händen greifen kann und dadurch zum teil
schon einfach erliegen weil weil der zum
teil sehr viele leute sehen viele
institutionen die da hinten ja auf der
einen seite gibt es viele verletzte und
zahlreiche leute im rollstuhl oder jetzt
der kollege hier war auf den rollstuhl
sitzt war auf der anderen seite nie
diese präsenz bekommen wie wenn ich
jetzt nicht irgendwohin einzug so sei
zwar die leute schauen vielleicht auch
zu seite schauen
aber es gibt auch viele leute die im
raum quatschen oder anfragen was ist mit
ihnen passiert die den mut finden was
gesellschaftlich bräuchte damit
inklusion gelingt darüber werden wir am
schluss noch mal sprechen ich werde dann
noch mal zu ihnen kommen jetzt für den
ersten moment vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
richtig
ja und zu uns gestoßen sind jetzt svenja
goltermann sie ist professorin für
geschichte der neuzeit an der
universität zürich und hat ein viel
beachtetes buch geschrieben über den
begriff des opfers über die wahrnehmung
von krieg und gewalt in der moderne ein
buch über das sehr viel diskutiert
worden ist und bei uns ist auch bertram
eisenhower er ist verantwortlicher
redakteur für das was ihr leben bei der
sonntagsausgabe der faz und auch er
hatte ein großartiges buch geschrieben
weil ich ein dicker bin denen eines
lebensgefühls in dem er erzählt vom
dicksein vom abnehmen und von ganz
vielen unterschiedlichen eindrücken die
auf diesem weg einen begegnen
ganz herzlich willkommen ihnen beiden
frau goltermann der opfer begriff der
interessiert mich wir sprechen von
verbrennungsopfern von unfallopfern von
kriegsopfern gleichzeitig beschimpfen
sich kinder heute auf dem pausenhof mit
dem wort du opfer
was ist mit diesem opfer begriff
passiert warum ist der heute ist negativ
konvertieren
warum er heute so negativ konnotiert ist
ist ehrlich gesagt im augenblick noch
sehr schwer zu sagen was ich interessant
finde ich gucke mir als historikerin
längere zeiträume an und bei der
geschichte die ich über die wahrnehmung
von menschen denen irgendein unglück
zugestoßen ist oder die extreme
belastung erlebt haben was mir da
aufgefallen ist dass der begriff ein
opfer von etwas geworden zu sein
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert die meiste
zeit negativ konnotiert ist es ist eine
relativ kurze zeit historisch gesehen in
der menschen sich ohne irgendwie ohne
weitere probleme ein opfer nennen können
und das sind ich würde sagen das fängt
so in den späten siebziger jahren an und
geht so bis zur jahrtausendwende
aber wer ein opfer ist kann ja zum
beispiel auch ansprüche geltend machen
so denken wir ja auch von diesem opfer
begriff passt könnte ja erst einmal
interessant sein
naja es ist schwierig weil wir sind
heute sind wir schon in einer situation
oder seit dem ausgehenden zwanzigsten
jahrhundert dass sich eine zunehmende
anzahl von menschen tatsächlich als
opfer bezeichnen kann oder sagen kann
ich bin ein opfer von etwas geworden und
diese ausweitung hängt damit zusammen
dass sich unsere vorstellungen davon was
eigentlich gewalt ist im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert auch verändert haben
es geht nicht mehr nur um körperliche
gewalt es geht nicht mehr nur um
menschen denen die körperliche
integrität verletzt worden ist sondern
wir haben heute auch einen begriff davon
dass es zum beispiel psychische gewalt
gibt dass menschen auch psychisch an
etwas leiden können das ist das gibt es
auf diese art und weise in der ersten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
nicht und diese menschen sind nicht
einheitlich
also sie können nicht alle gelten machen
entschädigungs anforderungen stellen
ihre ansprüche geltend machen
jetzt hat ja folien herr martinz ganz
deutlich gesagt mitleid das brauchte er
nicht und opfer zu sein ich sagen die
auch eng mit dem begriff des mitleids
oder das mitleiden verwoben wie denken
sie darüber
1000 mitleid ist das auch etwas was sie
von sich weisen und sagen
darauf kann ich nun wirklich verzichten
ja ich glaube dass
mitleid ja vor allem etwas mit dem mit
der person macht den beobachtet sieht
dass jemand vielleicht ein opfer ist
oder anders ist als man selbst
man hat ja neben mitleid dieses mitleid
es letztendlich gefühl dass die personen
aushalten muss und die person beobachtet
wird kann gar nichts dafür bezug würde
der person ja vielleicht auch gar nicht
in die situation bringen wollen
wir werden hier fährt wechselt glaube
ich manchmal den unterschied zwischen
empathie und mitleid und also mitleid
ist etwas wovon beide glaube ich sich
nichts kaufen können also wo wir auch
nicht weiter kommen als als sagen wir
mal in der situation oder auch als
gesellschaft was ich mir viel mehr
wünsche ist sowas wie empathie also
zusehen dass es menschen gibt die anders
sind und vielleicht andere
herausforderungen haben als man selbst
und dann sich irgendwie strategien
entweder gemeinsam zu überlegen wie ich
jetzt wesentlich oder die wir gemeinsam
aus dieser bislang offensichtlich das
beste daraus machen also weniger so
dieses vom hohen ross heraus mitleid
empfinden sondern stärker miteinander
fühlen und für einer unter denken und
ein stehen vielleicht aber auch
gemeinsamkeiten entdecken also
gemeinsame situationen wo man sich
ähnlich oder ähnlich mal gefühlt hat als
die personen die man gerade in
eine herausforderung steckt und diese
sei die gemeinsame ebene zu finden ist
die große herausforderung unserer zeit
und und dann letztendlich auf sich zu
überlegen wie wir doch endlich wieder
reisen sie entsprechen ja auch nicht der
norm und würden sie sagen dieses nicht
der norm entsprechen ist für sie an sich
problematisch oder ist ihr übergewicht
für sie nur dann problematisch wenn es
darum geht dass es ihren alltag
beeinträchtigt oder ihre gesundheit
beeinträchtigt nein das beeinträchtigt
meine gesundheit natürlich und die älter
ich werde umso stärker empfinde ich das
ich habe aber auch also der sandte
impuls für das buch war dass ich
irgendwann angefangen habe
aufzuschreiben immer wenn ich so momente
hatte wo ich dachte dass etwas mit
meinem übergewichts tun was ich gerade
erlebe und und habe mich dann mir
notizen gemacht und immer so eine sprach
notiz gemacht
dann habe ich angefangen wenn ich wusste
gar nicht genau wieso und ich hatte dann
habe ich angefangen so kleine video
aufnahmen zu machen bin ich wieder meine
diät angefangen habe das war auch sehr
frustrierend weil ich irgendwie 25
videoschnipsel zu hause hat wo ich immer
den ersten tag einer diät anfangen und
dann im zweiten oder dritten tag
gebracht habe ich wieder abgebrochen
wenn man muss sich wieder sagen heute
ist übrigens der erste tag der diät und
und ich dachte irgendwie so an
irgendwann schreibe ich mal drüber und
machen ein videofilm also was drüber und
in dem buch habe ich dann habe ich die
kolumne geschrieben wir unsere zeitung
und zuerst auch anonymen weil ich hatte
so den eindruck wieso über das das
dicksein geredet wird in der
gesellschaft wird immer mit so einer mit
so einer gewissen flockig kite drüber
gesprochen immer ach ich und meine
problemzonen und a ha und ich fand
erstmalig fand das musste mal gesagt
werden dass aber darunter ein schmerz
ist das ist jetzt ich kann mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht vorstellen wie der herr
mattes oder auch krauthausen wie die so
mit diesem
also sagen mit diesem leben so umgehen
weil im vergleich ist sozusagen das
päckchen oder den knacks dem ich habe
ein ein kinderspiel gehäuse aber aber
ich hatte so den eindruck dass die art
und weise wie ich mich so als ticker
verstanden habe seit ich das als problem
wahrgenommen habe als teenager dass das
auf meine seele durchgeschlagen hat dass
die art und weise wie ich mich als
ticker so empfinde die die art sozusagen
einfärbt wie ich wichtig zur welt und
ich sage immer dass es das übergewicht
verkürzt einem das leben in dem man
nicht so lange lebt statistisch gesehen
aber es beschneiden einem der
sammelliste ich meine auch damit dass es
einem das leben beschneidet es stiehlt
einem lebens das ist ja auch sehr sehr
deutlich wird das eigentlich im buch
etwa sich aber fragen sie haben gerade
den kopf geschüttelt als er gesagt habt
im vergleich zu ihnen sei seine sein
dick sein sozusagen ein kinderspiel oder
ja also ich kenne leute die topfit und
depressionen haben
ich kenne leute die im rollstuhl sitzen
und die größe die scherzbolde und
fröhlichsten menschen sind die jede
meinem leben getroffen habe und ich
glaube es steckt mehr sagen wir mal so
es ist auch eine frage von residenzen
die wir im laufe unserer kinder oder auf
unseres lebens entwickelt haben
er hat mir ein bestärken das umfeld oder
hatten ein umfeld das uns vielleicht
stigmatisiert und und ausgelöscht hat
wie viele raketen haben wir im laufe
unseres lebens überwinden müssen oder wo
hat uns auch die umwelt dabei geholfen
barrieren zu überwinden so dass das eine
ganz individuelle frage so da habe ich
gar nicht so sehr etwas mit der mit
einer behinderung und weiter sagt dass
ein wenig auf wegen und müssen etwas was
diese geschichten jetzt verbindet ist
ein punkt den sie in ihrem buch so schön
benennen sie sagen nämlich der körper
ist unsere schnittstelle zu wählen
und dass der körper damit können sie
auch gleich oder dass der körper ein
sozusagen eben schnittstelle zur welt
auch das eintrittstor der reaktionen der
oder man würde gerne wissen man würde
gerne menschen gegenüber treten also
eine persönlichkeit aber das erste was
die menschen angesehen ist eben nicht
die persönlichkeit
sie sollen sie erleben einen zunächst
mal als einen körper als ein objekt und
es ist ja ganz der körper hat ja eine
ganz komische stellung so im leben also
sagen jeder jeder hat einen also das ist
sozusagen ein äußeres objekt in gewisser
weise aber jeder ist auch ein körper
also ist die enge verschränkung darüber
reden wir vielleicht noch aber zwischen
sozusagen körper und selbst natürlich
hat sich das verändert historisch
gesehen die rolle des körpers sozusagen
für unsere identität für unser selbst
ich denke schon wobei man natürlich
sagen muss dass sie immer eine rolle
gespielt hat also auch im neunzehnten
jahrhundert hat sie gespielt die ganze
mode ist darauf abgestellt etwas mit dem
körper zu machen und nach außen zu
zeigen etwas zu zeigen was man isst oder
was man nicht sein will zu verstecken
was ich aber wichtig finde dabei ist was
der körper ist und wir aufgenommen wird
und wir wahrgenommen wird ist nichts was
an sich natürlich und gegeben ist
sondern wir setzen die normen wir setzen
die norm schon und das können sie am
einfachsten dann feststellen wenn sie
sagen wir mal nach lateinamerika gehen
das dicksein hat dort einen ganz anderen
stellenwert wenn eine eine dicke frau in
lateinamerika ist es wird anders
angesehen ist gilt als schön
während die die ganz dünnen ja dort
nicht die dieses ideal der schönheit
empfohlen und das finde ich führt einem
immer wieder vor augen dass da was
gemacht wird dass wir das setzen genau
es gibt dieses setzen der normen und
dann kann man ja aber auch sein körper
noch verändern und das ist eine frage
die ganz bestimmt vielen zuschauern
unter den nägeln brennt nämlich die
frage warum er eisenhower wenn sie so
leiden unter ihrem übergewicht und ja
auch wirklich sehr sehr schwer krank
waren der sommer lange auf der
intensivstation laden warum ändern sie
es nicht wissen sie
das so genau wüsste also es gibt also
ich habe sehr lange jahre habe ich das
dass ich damit dass sich das nicht in
den griff bekommen habe das ist also der
vorwurf an den an den dicken begriff
sein leben nicht in den griff
obwohl viele dicke so erfolgreich sind
aber dieses eine phänomen dieses eine
dinge in ihrem leben
das kriegen sie nicht in den griff und
ich habe das lange jahre alles ein
persönliches versagen betrachtet dass
sich das lied ihn gekriegt hab ich habe
auf der anderen seite aber auch gemerkt
wenn ich versucht habe ist los zu werden
also wenn ich dann sport mit sport
gemacht habe und diät gemacht habe dass
ich da auch irgendwie gegen meinen
eigenen körper einen krieg für einen
ständigen das war dann sozusagen der
körper die nicht völlig extern avisiert
habe das war dann für mich der feind der
musste nieder gerufen werden das ist
auch nicht gesund glaube ich letztlich
gedanklich ich habe aber wie gesagt
immer auch gemerkt er sträubt sich auch
irgendwie dagegen jetzt in letzter zeit
lese ich immer häufiger es gibt da
irgendwie stoffwechsel sachen viele
dicke übrigens in gar nicht auszusagen
eigenen versagen oder so dick sondern
sie haben eine eine erkrankung zunehmend
bestimmte medikamente
da gibt es vieles und woher das bei mir
genau kommt ich wäre auch am liebsten so
eine filmfigur wo der drehbuchautor
zudem dass der drehbuchautor sollen
interessante wunde mit gibt so in der
kindheit wo man irgendeine klassicher
ich habe das bisher nicht finden können
aber aber sehr einfacher sie hätten es
um sich sozusagen zu erklären ja es ist
die frage ist auch immer dann wenn sie
es wenn sie erst mal verstanden haben
können es dann auch wirklich ändern
es ist ja so ich weiß es nicht also es
hat mich schon eine menge kraft gekostet
es immer wieder zu versuchen und
realistischer weise ist es auch so dass
viele andere leute ich habe das buch
geschrieben nachdem ich so einen
jahrelangen abnehmen kurs gemacht und
das war auch in einer gruppe mit anderen
leuten und realistischer weise ist es so
dass die wenigsten von diesen diäten
selbst sehr sachen diese richtig state
of the art sind mit ernährungsumstellung
und alles dass die am ende
den wenigsten zu einem erfolg führen das
ist wie gesagt verantwortung ist eine
schwere sache festzuschreiben
es ist an der zeit pedro lenz zuzuhören
einem starken word künstler und
schweizer schriftsteller auch er hat
sich seine gedanken zum thema normalität
gemacht
das glaubt schützen kritische wort eben
noch auch nochmal büßen box office
verletzt eine nicht so normal und gut
aber wenn das ganz normal mexiko sind
normalerweise sehr bemerkenswertes
gespür jeder versteht der typisch
richtig richtig aber normal sein
verhalten sich sorgen oder genauigkeit
und mit ihm die maschine soll ich mich
für ungut aber das ist nur normal
bewegen ist jedenfalls recht aber hart
ich das richtige tue dies nicht weil
strom jetzt bitte nicht falsch und
intoleranz oder auch die von hotel
pflege von mädels heute ist klar es darf
noch mal nach normalität
normalerweise der normalität
das ist logisch war einfach nur mal ein
spruch zu den quests für haute er ist
schon normal
für die normalerweise haben um mal
mutter vergleichs wie es verhältnismäßig
normal
immer wenn der nachbar schrieben sie
der candy juni dann müssen die innerhalb
von einer woche normal aussieht wie zum
beispiel china sogar zu der normalen
demnach sicher ob wir überhaupt noch mal
alle rhi und trotzdem normal das ist
normal das ist normal das ist wie normal
das entziehe abnormalität versucht ums
klavier nochmals fast normal wenn mehr
als ein normaler wirtschaft normaler
vielleicht noch mal auf die auf normalen
und datanorm umzug weiß oder als nachher
führten mit gewöhnlichen bürger nicht
normal und ausgefüllt machen's möglich
mit step brice normales fertigen heute
schon vieles noch mal wo man früher noch
abnormal oder sogar unmöglich eckfahne
normalität ist großer worte und wieder
gefasst und so und in der hauptvorteil
womit es sehr allgemein als normaler
glück twitter firma platz aus früheren
das gehört zum ganz normaler wandel
vorbereiten
aber wenn de ein technisches know-how
sie als abnormal ausstatten damit gegen
die noch einen ganz normal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie hat mit ihrem auftritt am eurovision
song contest den zeitgeist getroffen
[Musik]
conchita alias tom neuwirth hat nicht
nur mit ihrem gesang überzeugt sondern
auch mit ihrer botschaft
es sei eben wurst woher man kommt welche
sexuelle orientierung man hat und in
welchem körper man steckt ihre tolerante
botschaft schlägt eine erstaunliche
brücke in die menschheitsgeschichte
[Applaus]
unser körper war schon immer mehr als
nur pure anatomie einerseits
arbeitsgerät aber auch vehikel für
projektionen unseres geistes bereits die
australischen aborigines verorteten sich
durch ihren körper in der mystischen
welt wanderten mit ihm durch reale und
geträumte landschaften andere beispiele
legen nahe dass gestaltungstechniken wie
das tätowieren das setzen von
brandmarken und narben zeichnungen so
alt sind wie die felsenmalereien über
ursprung und bedeutung in den
verschiedenen kulturen lässt sich nur
spekulieren
klar ist es ihre anwendung weit über
ästhetische aspekte hinaus ging
die zeichen und bilder bekamen magisch
rituelle funktionen definierten die
stammeszugehörigkeit und den sozialen
rang des individuums die südsee und
deren völker wurden durch europäische
seefahrer im späten 18ten jahrhundert
entdeckt
ebenso ihre hochentwickelte tätowierer
kultur
[Musik]
sogenannt edle wilde die man nach europa
brachte begeisterten ein staunendes
publikum mit ihrem merkwürdigen haut
schmuck und wurden zum vorbild einer
neuen und eigenständigen
weiterentwicklung der tätowier kunst die
erfindung der tätowiermaschine 1891 löst
einen boom aus einzelne tätowierer
bemühten sich um anerkennung als
ernstzunehmende künstler tätowierungen
waren wie heute auch im ersten drittel
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ein
massenphänomen selbst großer
staatsmänner waren tätowiert churchill
mit anker roosevelt mit familienwappen
und stahlen mit totenkopf
[Musik]
so sind die heutigen bestrebungen mit
dem körper etwas auszudrücken und aus
der masse herauszuragen überhaupt nichts
neues sondern nur das nächste kapitel
einer langen geschichte
bezeichnend für unsere heutige zeit die
individualisierung geht mit dem drang
nach selbstvermarktung einher
[Musik]
körperkult bedeutet nicht einfach
zugehörigkeit zu einer gruppe sondern
identität und abgrenzung von anderen
[Musik]
er ist eine beschäftigung mit sich
selbst die praktisch nie abgeschlossen
ist ein perpetuum mobile des
egozentrismus unabhängig oder sagen wir
jenseits des geschlechtes
[Musik]
vielleicht am weitesten gehen jene
zeitgenossen die sich nicht nur
tätowieren lassen sondern bewusst auch
operative mittel anwenden um das normale
äußere zu verändern und sich so vom
mainstream abzusetzen
die körper künstlerinnen seine jaspers
gehört zu ihnen
sie zeigt dass dem ausdruckswillen noch
lange keine grenzen gesetzt sind ja bei
mir sitzen jetzt zwei menschen die ihr
äußeres freiwillig verändern und ihr
anderssein in gewisser weise auch
zelebrieren das ist zum einen die
drag-queen enya face alias tristan
eckert und zum anderen die
körperkünstlerin sende jaspers die wie
soeben im meer beitrag gesehen haben
zuerst möchte ich kurz bei ihnen bleiben
was haben sie denn alles mit ihrem
körper machen lassen bzw die frage was
ist er noch echt an ihn
naja das meinst du sieht man ja von den
tattoos immer im gesicht ziehen haben
die gedehnten oder sie sind die hier in
wordpress ist ein großes piercing die
eckzähne eckzähne die zunge haben wir
schon gesehen ich mir nochmal sehen
die elfen gespitzte ohren hier oben
gespitzte ohren und dann diese großen
genau die max
das ist das erste was man so sieht wir
möchten nicht anguckt gibt es etwas an
ihrem körper das ihnen besonders gefällt
besonders nicht eigentlich ist es so das
gesamtpaket was ich mir erarbeitet habe
aber das sind halt schon viele einzelne
dinge die so als ganzes land
zusammenkommen
die ich im einzelnen nicht mehr missen
wollte was bedeutet ihnen ihren körper
einerseits ist es wieder ein spielfeld
ich kann ihn so gestalten wie er mir
gefällt andererseits das ist ein
ausdruck von dem was für mich als
idealbild von schönheit darstellt und
ich kann mit meinem körper machen was
ich will ihn so ziehen und schmücken wie
ich das möchte und das ist das einzige
was mir alleine gehört was würden sie
verlieren sieht alles wieder rückgängig
machen müssten
ein bisschen meine identität mal dass
das ist was ich lebe das ist das was ich
immer wollte das ist ich lebe in dieser
blase drin von body modification ssig
arbeite damit um das wäre schon ein
bisschen ein verlust von mir selber und
dieses kunstwerk ist dass irgendwann
fertig nein wahrscheinlich nie
irgendwann wird mir der platz ausgehen
aber deshalb bin ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen spaß haben so viel platz ist
nicht mehr aber das ist veränderung die
das ganze leben dauert das ist nichts
das ich so ein fertiges bild habe und
dann sage okay ich habe erreicht dass es
eine veränderung die das ganze leben
dauert auch sie einige fans haben sich
verändert das hat nicht jahre gedauert
sondern immerhin drei stunden ja von
einem männlichen äußeren zu einem
weiblichen was haben sie denn alles
gemacht jetzt in diesen drei stunden
vielleicht können sie das machen wir ja
ich stehe vielleicht habe ich angefangen
von den schulen natürlich high heels
machen immer schön lange beine
dann haben wir vier paar tänzer
strumpfhosen meine künstlichen hüften
also nicht ein hüftgelenk nee also zwar
nicht aber ich finde es geschafft gummi
hüften drin dann damit italien schön
schmal wird ein konzept seither kann ich
auch nicht mehr zu mir nehmen was nicht
im shop glas bis passt und dann
natürlich die die echt aussehenden
brüste ich denke das sind nur
hähnchenbrüste schnitzel dann natürlich
die 700 schritte make up und die perücke
die auch und also bei mir sagen dieses
gegen halt alles was man sieht es nicht
nicht
und sie sind jetzt als dragqueen hier
was ist eine drag-queen eine drag-queen
dreck seine kultur oder an und kulturgut
aus der auf der queer szene
ich denke unterm strich ist es immer
noch wenn sich ein mann aus seiner frau
verkleidet es gibt aber so viele so
kulturen oder so viele unterarten davon
dass sicher für mich entscheidet das
mindeste was für mich ausmacht ist dass
man lippenstift high heels und braucht
dazu
was ist der reiz des ganzen für sie
persönlich es ist es ist für mich ein
lebensgefühl eine lebensfreude es ist
zwar aus den leuten rauszukriegen
genauso wenn vor allem wenn sie wissen
wie ich vorher ausgesehen habe und ich
denke es ist für mich das medium um
andere leute zu unterhalten oder innen
freude zu bereiten
steckt noch mehr dahinter aus
unterhaltung und spiele
naja ich kann kohle damit verdienen aber
nein also wenn sie jetzt auf sexuelles
an spielen zum beispiel nennt er daran
gedacht haben eine gesellschaftliche
botschaft ja im vergleich zu vielen
gästen heute bin ich ja die
light-version denn es ist temporär und
freiwillig dass ich anders aussehen
aber ich habe mich dass heute auch
selber gefragt was für eine botschaft
vermittle ich oder vertrete ich eine
gerade überhaupt oder wenig macht das
nur für mich aber ich denke schon aus
der tatsache heraus dass ich zu dem
auftritt oder zu einer zu einer show wie
in öffentlichen verkehrsmittel oder zu
fuß gehen sondern immer eine nummer
wählen oder ein taxi oder mich vor ort
bereit machen sagt eigentlich etwas über
meine eigene angst angst doch auch
wieder aus dass ich man weiß man kann an
ecken und es sind ja nicht ein trans
person muss man vielleicht sagen sie
möchten nicht eine frau hat sich fühlen
sich auch nicht als frauen sondern ist
eine rolle die sie die sie einnehmen und
bei ihnen seien die us pass ist ja so
sie können nicht mehr so schnell zurück
in das normale sozusagen die air liquide
anderen haben sie immer geschieht ihnen
solche kennen sie solche geschichten
auch von der von der straße die leute
einfach belästigen darf anstarren
beleidigen
ja ohne das würde das wahrscheinlich gar
nicht funktionieren das ist einfach in
der gesellschaft so dass alles was
anders ist oder ob normal wirkt
angesprochen angequatscht oder
provoziert wird was ich extrem merke ist
dass viele leute den unglaublichen drang
haben mir ihre ungefragte meinung
kundzutun
also weniger dass leute kommen sagen hey
ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool
sondern dass sie dann kommen sagen ich
finde das total scheiße
gefällt dir das überhaupt nein ich finde
es schrecklich das ist also ein bisschen
man kann das ja normal frage denkst du
findest es auch schön im alter oder
warum gefällt das aber das ist ein
urteil das es sich gefällt haben ohne
überhaupt mit mir zu sprechen also die
gehen davon aus dass auch ich das
hässlich finden müssen dass jemand
normal ist das nicht schön finden kann
was ich ihr aber tue und das ist so ein
bisschen das problem was die leute haben
dass sie vielleicht mehrmals zu leuten
zu gehen sollten und sagen hey mehr
gefällt das war nicht aber ich find's
cool dass du das machst oder hell mir
gefällt das weil die frage ist auch oft
gefällt einem das wirklich nicht oder
hat einem die gesellschaft gesagt dass
man so etwas nicht schön finden soll
oder kann das ist abnormal also gucken
wir weg die eltern sind die kinder weg
weil sowas darf man nicht das ist
irgendwie schlecht und böse aber warum
genau das haben wir schon gehört dass
diese normen nach gesetzt werden der
körperbilder die schönheits
vorstellungen usw
wenn ich jetzt hier einfach fragen würde
warum machen sie das
haben sie eine antwort weil das für mich
das idealbild von schönheit ist und ich
mir das nicht ausgewählt habe dass die
gesellschaft das nicht schön findet das
ist das problem finden was sie möchten
nicht provozieren sondern sie finden das
erstellen müssen damit leben dass sie
ein rauen und das andere das hässlich
finden oder aber gefallen ja auch sachen
nicht also ich finde auch sachen nicht
stören aber ich würde dann trotzdem
nicht irgendwohin gehen sagen das hätte
es nicht wir kennen uns zwar nicht aber
das sieht cacau aus also warum sollte
ich das mal schönstes naja schönste sich
nicht wahr
es ist ein schwarzer es ist
zu hell für ja schon mit ein bisschen
bereit aber diese hang zum dunklen zum
abgründigen woher kommt er bei ihnen das
weiß ich nicht das war schon immer da
das ist viele fragen mich auch immer wie
ich denn so geworden bin und ich bin der
meinung dass man nicht so wird sondern
dass man so ist entweder man unterdrückt
das dann ob vom elternhaus wäre das
nicht toleriert wird oder man lebt
irgendwie ein anderes leben in eine
andere richtung aber nie sein eigenes
und entweder ich sage immer man ist als
frisch geboren und lebt das nicht man
wird nicht so man wird nicht plötzlich
morgens auf und findet okay ich will
jetzt meinen ganzen körper zu tätowieren
und eckzähne und eine gespaltene zunge
haben das ist etwas das man entweder
schon immer schön fand und dann
irgendwann lebt oder halt einfach nicht
wie ist das bei ihnen
wie hängen rolle und person zusammen wie
hängt der christian eggert mit dieser
dragqueen enya fest zusammen
gute frage ich denke ohne dass es
schizophren klingen soll es ist ein und
gleiche person in einigen bewegungen
bewegungsabläufen unterscheiden sie sich
bestimmt die beiden beispielsweise so
die haare nach hinten und das war
natürlich nicht wenn man keine ahnung
hat kurze haare trägt und es gibt dann
aber die diskussions gestik oder auch
wie man überhaupt schon geht nur schon
wegen den deswegen hat gegen das gesetz
diese unterschiede spielen die passieren
automatisch aber vom vom humor her vom
von der lebensfreude
das ist natürlich ein und dieselbe
person
im unterschied zu marcel mathis und
anderen gästen heute wählen sie diese
veränderung selbst die die mit einem
gewissen auffallen einhergeht in der
gesellschaft wollen sie auch ein
bisschen provozieren oder ist das
einfach nur unangenehme nebensache aber
nicht den provozieren möchte niemandem
bewusst außer vielleicht meine eltern
aber ich gehe auch nur wirklich dorthin
wo ich denn als direkt gebucht werden
also ich drehe mich niemandem auf und
wie gesagt wenn nicht wenn ich die
aufmerksamkeit nicht wo ich wenn ich
weiß wo sie nicht gefragt dass wir auch
in der öffentlichkeit und sodann dann
bin ich halt in einem taxi oder dann
werde ich hingefahren und
da wo ich in den clubs und in den
lokalitäten wo ich dann gefragt bin da
widerfährt nicht nur liebe und dann
denke auch das ist der falsche ansatz
wenn man provozieren will
wenn man das macht oder so viel
veränderung in kauf nimmt nur um zu
provozieren macht man das wieder für wen
anders das ist dann nicht mehr für sich
selber sondern an willigen statement
setzen man will auf weil man mit anders
sein und nicht für sich selber zum sich
selber verwirklichen sondern um zu
provozieren oder aufzubauen und das ist
für mich persönlich nicht der richtige
weg wenn jetzt alle menschen so aussehen
würden wie sie cool mit dem
bankengeschäft muss man noch dazu sagen
aber sie werden das genauso schön
ja das ist ja nichts was mir gehört wenn
auch leute immer sagen ich wünschte ich
könnte das auch das kann man auch dass
ich kann nichts spezielles das kann
jeder der sagt ich will das leben der
kann das machen
da muss aber einfach mit allen
konsequenzen leben können also das ist
nicht so
ich will das zwar aber ich will nicht
auf waren ja ich will das war aber ich
will nicht dass die leute mich ansehen
das geht nicht
entweder als ganzes oder gar nicht was
muss denn passieren damit das geht
sie muss sich unsere gesellschaft
verändern was muss ich ihnen köpfen
verändern damit ihr das ein ding machen
kann
die leute müssen bestimmt mal versuchen
zu überlegen was ist meine persönliche
meinung nur weil ich jetzt was gesehen
habe urteile ich darüber und sage das
muss bestimmten satanist sein oder die
trink blut oder wort aber was sie nicht
tun was nicht
also meine kunden gehen mit genau gleich
viel blut wieder raus die leute sehen
etwas und urteilen und dann müsste man
sich mal hinterfragen ist es das was ich
wirklich schlecht finde oder hässlich
finde oder ist dass das was mir
eingetrichtert wurde
deshalb sind kinder auch so neutral
kinder kommen sagen finde ich cool oder
wenn ich blöd aber das sind sie selber
bevor die eltern ding erklärt haben nein
das muss so schlecht finden
und wenn mehr leute auf ihr inneres
hören würden und da drauf gehen dann
wäre alles schon viel einfacher herzlich
dagegen beiden für dieses gespräch
dann kam
ja und bei uns sitzt wiederum eine neue
person sich scheller ist philosoph und
kunsttheoretiker und unter anderem
dozent an der zürcher hochschule der
künste und die hersteller haben unter
anderem über arnold schwarzenegger
promoviert arnold schwarzenegger oder
die kunst ein leben zu stemmen
und sie sagen bodybuilding und darum
geht es in diesem buch natürlich auch
das ist etwas da geht es nicht darum
dass man anderen gefallen will sondern
man will in erster linie auffallen wie
kommen sie zu dieser these nun ja ich
habe zum einen viele bodybuilder
kennengelernt auch bodybuilder rinnen
kennen gelernt und kann insofern wie
empirisch sagen diesen menschen geht es
nicht darum eine mainstream ideal zu
entsprechen sondern im gegenteil aus dem
mainstream heraus zu stechen
eine radikale wenn sie so wollen
subkultur eine radikale avangard zu
bilden und diese avantgarde die ist
recht interessant dahingehend in den
zusammenhängen die wir hier diskutieren
das die bodybuilder gewissermaßen die
norm soweit zuspitzen und überspitzen
dass die norm ins gegenteil gibt also
sind einig kipp figuren also die
selbstoptimierung die sagen das training
des körpers für fitness zwecke wird
soweit zugespitzt dass der körper
eigentlich ins das funktionale kippt das
heißt da sehen wir eigentlich sehr schön
dass wenn wir das normale auf die spitze
treiben da ist eben auch mal dann wird
es auch normal also das normale ist
nicht das gegenteil von abnormalen und
umgekehrt sondern das abnormale kann das
wieder brave soldat schwejk eigentlich
die über erfüllung von bestimmten
befehlen oder von bestimmten erwartungen
bedeuten und überzeugt dass die beiden
gäste vorhin auch gesagt haben sie
hätten das einfach schön oder denken sie
den ideen geht es schon auch ums
auffallen wenn alle tätowiert werden
alle solche implantate hätten dann wäre
es auch gar nicht mehr interessant
zumindest nicht auf dem rad
er müsste schon etwas länger direkt
unterhalten
haben kann ich so schlecht sagen weil
wir uns nicht genau kennen also die
persönlichen motivation weiß ich in dem
fall natürlich nichts aber ganz
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so dass
selbst schönheit etwas ist mit dem man
auffällt es auch schönheit ist etwas mit
dem man heraus sticht schönheit ist
nicht die norm und insofern wenn man
also sagen würde ich möchte einfach
schön sein kann das auch bedeuten dass
ich aus oder sind zumindest der
normalität vielleicht nicht morgen aber
aus der normalität herausstechen werde
ob ich das möchte oder nicht
und die wird gerne noch eine these von
ihnen aufnehmen weil ich diese
interessant finde die haben sie in einem
interview gesagt
für esskultur dass man auch weiterhin
noch nachlesen kann auf unserer website
und da sagen sie wir brauchen den freak
um uns selber irgendwie auch normal zu
fühlen
das heißt wir klopfen und finden das
alles interessant um uns darin zu
bestätigen dass wir ganz schön normal
sind verstehe ich das richtig verstehen
sie vollkommen richtig also wir müssen
alle sehr sehr dankbar sein dass es die
bodybuilder und andere freaks gibt
bodybuilder ist auch eine subkultur wo
der fried begriff auf die bodybuilder
selbst angewendet wird das entsprechend
auch von sich selbst als freaks als
monster zum teil als masse freaks und
insofern vor einem bodybuilder dieses
beispiel zu wählen
kommen wir uns wie natur kinder vor wir
haben uns vielleicht noch ein bisschen
das näschen richten lassen wir gehen
oder dreimal die woche zum kieser
training und fühlen uns wie die reihe
natur kinder die bodybuilder sagen wir
haben es immer noch attraktiv natur ist
immer noch attraktiv auch wenn es sie
nicht mehr gibt wahrscheinlich ist sie
genau das ging so attraktiv weil kein
mensch mehr weiß was ist eigentlich ist
ich würde gerne zu ihnen kommen herr
krauthausen nicht interessiert eine ganz
grundlegende frage wir haben es ganz
unterschiedliche formen dessen kennen
gelernt was es heißt mit seinem körper
schnittstelle zur welt nicht der norm zu
entsprechen und man könnte ja bösartig
sagen sie kümmern sich um inklusion sie
kämpfen für eine welt in der alle
menschen gleiche chancen haben zb
barrierefrei durchs leben kommen und
dann gibt es menschen die verwenden ihre
gesamte zeit die gesamtes geld darauf
möglichst sich selber so ein bisschen zu
optimieren sind sie da auch so tolerant
wie wir es bis anhin gehört haben und
sagen dann irgendwann noch entschuldigen
dass ich jetzt echt ein anderes kapitel
können wir hier mal über die wirklichen
probleme sprechen also in der berger
schick vermessen wenn ich sowas sagen
würde und ich bin da eher weil bei
freundeskreis also wer bin ich dass ich
das beurteilen darf wie jemand sein
leben gestaltet wer bin ich dass ich
sagen der sage irgendwie investiere mal
deine zeit sinnvoll
was ich aber gerade ganz interessant war
eine ganz andere beobachtungen die hier
in der sendung gerade mache inwieweit
bestätigen wir hier eigentlich gerade
die freakshow erzählen sie also es gab
letzten jahrhundert noch gab es ein
wanderzirkus der kleinste mann der welt
der dicke mann der welt geht die
begehrteste frau der welt oder was auch
immer
zur schau gestellt wurden um dann wird
endlich das publikum zu amüsieren und
das war ein große ereignisse zwar ganze
dorffest hat man dort um veranstaltet
und jetzt sitzen wir hier also auf
bühnen und reden mit ihnen als normale
nicht betroffenen menschen und lassen
uns das dann von nicht betroffenen
wissenschaftlern einordnen und wir
bestätigt dies auf derart
interessant wenn dies eigentlich wenn
wenn hier ein betroffener
wissenschaftler setzte und das sind sie
visionen ich bin kein wissenschaftler
ich bin na ja in der inklusions
spezialisten deswegen sitzen sie dann
bei dilemma ist ja ich bin so genannter
berufs behinderter
das heißt ich bestätige diese situation
ja permanent ich bin als mensch mit
behinderung auf bühnen und gegenüber
behinderung dabei könnte ich auch über
social media geben
aber was soll ich will doch niemand
eingebaut vielleicht könnte ja
vielleicht leichter zu was sagen weil
wenn sie die betroffene
wissenschaftlerinnen haben möchten
können sie haben
ich bin eben gering ja aber dass solche
eingeladen ich bin ja solche eingeladen
weil es ist aber trotzdem eine
interessante seite daran weil sie haben
vorhin gesagt man sollte das publikum
nicht für dumm verkaufen und man könnte
irgendwie ruhig mal davon ausgehen sie
an irgendwie auch als normal irgendwie
so auffassen
wenn ich denke ich möchte das publikum
nicht für dumm verkaufen dann mache ich
das in dem ich sage dass ich
elektrikerin bin
das heißt für mich nämlich in dem
augenblick sie mit etwas zu
konfrontieren was sie im grunde genommen
läuft unter einer eigentlich erzählt man
sowas nicht das ist nämlich eine andere
kategorie von er jedenfalls in den
köpfen vieler von oder ist jemand
behindert
ich habe das auch ganz ganz lange
jahrzehnte kann ich mittlerweile schon
sagen von leuten ferngehalten und sie
nehmen medikamente und keine anfälle zu
kriegen
ich würde gerne die these der freakshow
ihnen weitergehe wie empfinden sie das
auch so finden sie den garten freaks
also so hart wie der kollege würde ich
das nicht sagen aber es ist ein
entscheidender unterschied zwischen
sagen bei uns beiden und und den beiden
die haben das selbst gewählt
und ich sehe das natürlich sagen ich
habe das haben auch ein bisschen
geschichte studiert ich sehe das auch in
die historische perspektive
es ist schon auch ein enormer
emanzipatorischer zu gewinnen
dass leute wie die beiden das machen
können es gibt wird sicherlich immer
leute geben die gucken was ist das für
eine bieten der sich an oder die sich an
aber trotzdem
man hat heutzutage eine also in der
deutschen geschichte versammlung aber
eine größere freiheit ein free zu sein
gab es in deutschland mit ausnahme des
leichtes berlins der zwanziger jahre gab
es nirgendwo
und das ist schon und da eben ist der
unterschied auch in der freiwilligkeit
und weil wir über den man sich über das
opfer gesprochen haben
mit dem opfer das ist ja eine schwierige
eine schwierige sache weil viele von den
gruppen die sich als opfer bezeichnen
heutzutage das ist sozusagen die
kehrseite eine emanzipationsgeschichte
wenn sie so wollen sagen die freiheit im
westen hat angefangen
revolutionen des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts die waren aber vornehmlich
für männer für begüterte männer in
amerika für begüterte sklavenhalter
männer und ist dann ausgeweitet worden
auf arbeiter auf frauen heutzutage hat
man immer mehr gruppen die der so hat
der kreis derer die sich als opfer
empfinden damit aber politische
forderungen zu verbinden und man muss
sich als opfer einer susan strukturellen
gewalt zum beispiel dass man definieren
damit man dann sagen kann ich will mich
ich will daraus wird immer größer wir
sind es bei transgender
wir sind also sagen schwule und lesben
das leben wir schon fast sozusagen als
normalverteilung hin
jetzt sind wir bei transgender die
umwelt die tiere so sagen diese diese
geschichten werden immer größer und
sagen unter emanzipatorische zuwachs in
der gesellschaft glaube ich wird auch
immer größer es gibt sicherlich auch
schließungs tendenzen überall aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass das auch von von
allen problemen abgesehen
es ist ein hohes anzuwachsen vielleicht
kann ich das natürlich beschäftigt und
diese geschichte der freakshow
die haben wir natürlich auch auf der
redaktion gewälzt und uns überlegt wie
machen wir das und ich finde interesse
das an mehreren stellen die frage aufkam
sind kinder nicht stärker darin mit
differenz umzugehen mit dem anderen uns
gehen die fragen einfach die sind dann
aber auch sehr schnell bereit das was
anders aussieht was anders ist
einzugliedern und dann einfach darauf
davon auszugehen die sind gleich wie wir
aber die sprechen auch miteinander die
gehen aufeinander zu und ich glaube das
war eigentlich das anliegen miteinander
ins gespräch zu kommen und
unterschiedliche formen der normalität
mal auszuloten mal zu gucken wer setzten
diese normen also wieso finden wir zum
beispiel dick seien übergewichtig sein
das ist eigentlich nicht normal
dementsprechend vom normalgewicht aber
wir haben die zahlen vor hingesehen eine
von fünf personen sind übergewichtigen
der schweizer seine hohe anzahl an sie
und ich setzen die normen zum beispiel
also eltern setzen sie in der
kindererziehung medien setzen sie auch
ständig weil medien sozusagen ist einer
der agenturen die diese normen
vielleicht nicht setzen aber doch
vermitteln und verstärken und und man
muss auch immer wieder sich fragen wie
den ästhetisieren die wirklichkeit
natürlich wenn sie mal im fernsehen
gucken oder im film die leute im film
oder im fernsehen sind immer im
durchschnitt 30 prozent hübscher als die
gesamtbevölkerung weil es einfach und
wir bevor wir hier angefangen haben sind
geschminkt worden
es ist einfach das in so ein bisschen
man hat sozusagen filmstars wofür werden
filmstars bezahlt sie werden dafür
bezahlt dass sie sozusagen die schönsten
denken waren exemplare des pcs mensch
sind ja sie haben wir nur so genügt oder
ich habe den eindrucksvoll was haben
dazu ich glaube dass das was sie gerade
beschrieben haben mit blick auf die
eröffnung auf die emanzipatorischen zu
gewinnen
dass wir da doch zurzeit sehr sehr
starke beck lashes erleben
es gibt eine neue sehnsucht nach
normalität es gibt eine neue sehnsucht
nach authentizität
es gibt eine sehnsucht nach so etwas wie
heimat z und das kann man eigentlich
sehr schön an bodybuilding ablesen es
gab eine phase der öffnung die gerade
mit diesen emanzipatorischen bewegungen
der 60er 70er 80er jahre
zusammenfiel also der phase der
postmoderne da waren diese bodybuilding
freaks die waren plötzlich interessant
für den mainstream also die kamen aus
diesen was die untergrundszene raus man
hat sich auf eine art und weise an denen
delektiert wie einer freakshow aber
gleichzeitig mit dem durchaus
authentischen und ehrlichen interesse
seit den 90er jahren wandert
bodybuilding und bodybuilding ist durch
eine extreme körper praxis da geht es um
das maximum an muskelmasse anders als in
fitness wo es eine funktional und
gemäßigt sein soll
seit 90 jahren das bodybuilding wieder
in etwas in die subkultur in den
untergrund abgewandert man spricht
wieder zunimmt negativ darüber eben als
abnormal das sind freaks im negativen
sinne
und man nutzten sie negativ vorbilder
wie gesagt um sich selbst wiederum als
normal zu konstituieren denn gefragt was
wir also ich bin ja jemand der sich für
inklusion einsetzt und wir haben alle
bücher geschrieben offensichtlich wert
jahr über das schreiben von büchern
sprechen können und dann ist es nicht
mehr ganz andere gemeinsamkeit und das
ist für mich zum beispiel oder wäre für
mich ein auftrag ein medien nicht diese
freak show zu machen sondern eben eine
illustre talkrunde zum thema das
schreiben von büchern wo die autorinnen
autoren diversen und wieso können wir
nicht unser thema so wählen dass wir
sagen wir sprechen jetzt mal gemeinsam
darüber was normal für uns bedeutet weil
ich ja gerade gesagt habe dass wir hier
lächerlich die bestätigung dieses
anderssein sind und dann aber
letztendlich vor allem uns einordnen
lassen von moderatorinnen moderatorin
von wissenschaftlerinnen von
wissenschaftlern die eben nicht geht
nicht fahren nicht tätowiert oder nicht
dreck sind obwohl aber da muss ich auch
mal widersprechen weil ich würde sagen
also mein ideal wäre auf jeden fall dass
es möglich sein sollte für menschen zu
sprechen über die art wie sie sich
anders nicht normal oder behindert
fühlen oder sie sollen das lassen
darüber zu sprechen
ich finde diese diese vorstellung man
muss darüber sprechen oder man muss
nicht darüber sprechen also auch das
andere dass man nicht darüber sprechen
solle
find ich genauso eine einschränkung weil
die bedürfnisse sind individuell höchst
verschieden
was ja auch damit zusammenhängt dass die
menschen die anders sind ich meine man
ist es aus unterschiedlichen grund es
gibt sie haben vorhin gesagt es ist ein
sich selbst sein
das ist die vorstellung sich selbst zu
sein warum soll man darüber nicht
sprechen können
das schlimme ist ja für sie wenn und
auch für sie möglicherweise wenn
menschen über sie urteilen dauernd ohne
dass man es überhaupt danach gefragt hat
ich klicke sehr detailliert und ich
glaube das ist die tiefe die diese
sendung auch erzeugen möchte also dass
dann jemand wäre ich eine provokante
these in den raum setzen und dann
natürlich gehen dieses tolle gespräch
kommen inklusion wäre es wirklich auch
anzunehmen ja und inklusion ist eben
kein kein ziel dass wir irgendeinen
bieter checkliste abraten können sondern
eher wissen prozess und zwar im prozess
der annahme und der bewältigung von
menschlicher vielfalt
das heißt anzunehmen dass wir auch eine
folkige wird die moderatorin die
schützen hätten haben können die über
das thema kultur in einer kultur sendung
spricht ohne dass das dann gleich wieder
thema sein ist und an dem punkt sind die
haie lange noch nicht und das ist etwas
was ich mir auch für uns als
gesellschaft wünschen würde ich würde
gern noch ich weiß nicht wie viel
sendezeit gemacht haben haben aber gab
es immer zu wenig verkauftem was werde
ich weiß aber ins erbgut test
vorgenommen ja eine sache ja zu sagen
und zwar wir müssen auch über die
freiwillig glück sprechen also dass
eigenen empfundenen glücks und mensch
mit behinderung menschen die dick sind
werden total auf von nichtbehinderten
wichtigen menschen unterstellt sie
müssen jetzt etwas dagegen tun
mir wurde mein leben lang gesagt ich
muss sport machen ja so lassen sie
sollen was dagegen tun also dass sich
der ja schon behinderten dass ich meinen
körper möglichst gesund ist das so die
idee gewesen und es gab die idee der
1000 operationen über mich ergehen zu
lassen
und ich kann mich an ein gespräch mit
meiner mutter erinnern wo die fragen im
raum stand operieren wir rauls bei ling
und eine mutter ist möglicherweise
ärztin und die frage war
wenn ich operiert werde dann könnte ich
vielleicht mit viel training und viel
krankenhaus und viele operationen zwei
drei schritte laufen und alle kinder in
meinem alter wurden damals in dem maße
operiert und meine mutter als ärztin hat
gesagt du musst das nicht machen weil
der einsatz das die jahren krankenhaus
sein wirst
wer so ist ein persönlich empfunden das
lebensglück das müssen geht es dann
diskutieren und wir haben es ich war
neun jahre lang diskutiert und die
entscheidung waren ich lasse mich nicht
operieren weil ich bin glücklich und das
glück einem abzusprechen
weil man dick ist oder weil man
behindert ist oder weil man tätowiert
ist oder weil man dreck macht das das
steht dem nicht betroffenen nicht zu
sie alle sind auch körper doch nicht mit
jedem körper kommt man gleich einfach
durch diese gesellschaft denn behindert
wird man ja auch sehr oft von der
gesellschaft als nicht behinderter
mensch kann man sich kaum vorstellen was
es für behinderte bedeutet in eine
straßenbahn einzusteigen
oder eine treppe zu erklimmen
oder eine trendsportart auszuüben
das leben ist voller hürden selbst wenn
es nicht behinderten gar nicht so
scheint wer jedoch denkt dass nur eine
minderheit vor diesem problem steht wird
sich allein in der schweiz gelten je
nach definition ist zu 1,6 millionen
menschen als behindert 26 prozent davon
also fast eine halbe million menschen
gelten als schwer beeinträchtigt die
schweiz sieht sich gerne als
behindertengerechtes land die sogenannte
inklusion also die integrierung von
behinderten in der gesellschaft wird
groß geschrieben
dennoch brauchte es auch hier unzählige
anläufe und eine jahrelange politische
auseinandersetzung
doch seit einigen jahren scheint unsere
gesellschaft intoleranz und
gleichgültiger geworden zu sein
dies belegen die zahlen des bundesamtes
für statistik
gemäss einer auswertung von 2015 hat
sich das subjektive wohlbefinden von
menschen mit starker behinderung um über
15 prozent verschlechtert davon kann
auch der thurgauer politiker christian
lohr ein lied singen
seit sieben jahren engagiert er sich im
nationalrat für seine anliegen
als eines der letzten kinder welches
aufgrund des beruhigungsmittels
contergan vorgeburtliche schäden
erlitten hatte war sein weg ein
steiniger
[Musik]
dennoch will er sich nicht auf sein
handicap reduzieren lassen
ich habe die ganze thematik mit mit dem
medikament dann für mich nie zu einem
lebensthema aufkommen lassen weil für
mich war klar das sind meine
lebensumstände meine lebensbedingungen
und mit denen habe ich zu leben
ja und der cvp nationalrat und
vizepräsident von pro infirmis sitzt
jetzt neben mir christian lohr raul
krauthausen wollte über das glück
sprechen und ich habe von ihnen gelesen
dass sie ihre behinderung nicht aus
benachteiligung empfinden können sie das
erläutern
das ist absolut richtig ich habe auch
starke glücksgefühle immer es ist
sicherlich manchmal eine gratwanderung
zwischen demut eigener wahrnehmung aber
doch auch dem bewusstsein dass mein
leben einen großen sinn macht nicht
trotz der behinderung das möchte ich
ausdrücklich sagen firma mit dieser
behinderung wie ich leben kann wie ich
ein authentisches leben führen kann wie
ich auch glücklich sein kann eben wie
ich eben immer wieder damit konfrontiert
bin der sich einerseits natürlich meine
andersartigkeit durchaus annehmen und
sie bewusst auch lebe weil sie ist ein
teil der realität anders ist diese
andersartigkeit für mich eine normalität
und ich denke mir gelingt es immer
wieder sehr gut dass sie in einem
gleichgewicht zu behalten
das braucht natürlich verbraucher
verschiedene umstände die sich ergeben
an der zeit sie mir in der diskussion
vorher ein bisschen problematisch als
man dann die die die erstbegegnung oder
den direkten kontakt nur auf den körper
zu beschränken verleben
für mich ist es eben auch eine frage
das wesen des menschen und da habe ich
manchmal nur wenn man auch gerade in
solchen diskussionen dann jedoch wieder
zu stark in china darfst verfällt aber
sind diese menschen die wenig kontakt
haben mit den körperlich behinderten
oder körperlichen sozusagen
auffälligkeiten sind die nicht auch in
diesen schemata drehen und erleben sie
das nicht so dass man erst mal irgendwie
auf ihre füße guckt und dass sie keine
arme haben und so als ich habe immer
mehr dass die leute mehr zuerst in die
augen schauen wie schauer auch zurück
und suche augenkontakt und da ich bei
mir
speziell das haben sie heute selber auch
wahrgenommen
meine erste begegnung findet eben nicht
einfach mit dem start was ich nicht habe
nämlich sondern mit dem was ich habe und
dass sie meine füße und grüßt sich alle
menschen offen direkt mit meinem fuß so
das ist wirklich alles ich bewundere wie
sie den alltag leisten von mails
schreiben bis bis zu zähneputzen und das
ist irgendwie für mich verblüffen sie
haben von demut gesprochen dass man dass
das annehmen dass sogar dem leben einen
sinn ergibt
heute erleben wir einen trend hin zur
verbesserung zur optimierung nicht nur
das körper sondern auch des geistes wie
beurteilen sie das
ja ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher
werde auf dem richtigen kurs sind
optimierung was was will das heißen wir
dass unsere situation will dass unsere
verhaltensweisen optimieren wollen wir
besser optimaler werfen damit unser
wohlstand besser wird dass unsere
umstände westler wir haben aber werden
wir als menschen mit unseren werten
damit wirklich besser
das ist für mich schon eine große frage
und sie bezweifeln dass es würde mich
natürlich interessieren was das
stattdessen bräuchte und wir haben über
behinderung gesprochen und das ist immer
nicht nur ein individuelles thema
sondern immer auch ein
gesellschaftliches politik politische
sie sind politiker engagieren sich in
auch in unterschiedlichen organisationen
und die schweiz sagen sie hat einen
großen erheblichen nachholbedarf was
behindertengerechtigkeit betrifft ich
glaube da muss man schon differenzieren
wir haben einige punkte wie schon der ob
im internationalen vergleich sagen wir
mehr als ordentlich entwickelt sind der
öffentliche verkehr ist in vielen
bereichen schon gut erreichbar
zugänglich da ist vieles gemacht worden
in den letzten jahren natürlich muss man
fortsetzen und dranbleiben damit dann
nicht auf einmal wieder neue barrieren
aufgebaut werden
es gibt aber andere bereiche da habe ich
schon das gefühl dass wir an einer
grundhaltung arbeiten müssen die offen
ob die tolerante wird die
verständnisvoller wird empathischer was
heißt das ganz konkret was braucht das
politisch ich denke ganz wichtig ist
dass wir wenn wir von integration oder
inklusion spreche neben uns bewusst sein
müssen dass es viele menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen gibt die die
gesellschaftliche teilhabe die breite
gesellschaftliche teilhabe heute noch
nicht haben und es ihnen nicht möglich
möglich ist ich möchte einige kurze
einige bereiche erwähnen die mir sehr
wichtig erscheint die bildung im
vordergrund
ich denke es ist enorm wichtig dass
junge menschen nicht nur einfach so weg
beschrieben ein recht auf eine bildung
haben sondern dass das auch umgesetzt
wird
woran scheitert das jetzt ganz konkret
wir haben eigentlich noch zu wenige
modelle die einerseits natürlich dem
gesamt anspruch einer schule gerecht
werden aber andererseits eben die
besonderen bedürfnisse die die menschen
oder die junge menschen mit besonderen
anforderungen haben dass man die ihnen
gewähren kann
es sollte eben aufgehört werden immer
das gegeneinander auszuspielen
ich habe manchmal das gefühl man sagen
entweder ist es möglich war nicht
möglich aber das leben ist kein
wunschkonzert und b ist es auch nicht
nur schwarz und weiß sondern größte teil
vom lebenswerk auge reicht
dann gibt es da brauche einen weiteren
preis den ich ganz bewusst hier erwähnen
möchte das ist natürlich die
arbeitsmarkt integration menschen mit
behinderungen für die ist das auch sehr
wichtig dass sie sich als arbeitskraft
einbringen können die arbeit bedeutet ja
auch die stärkung des selbstwertgefühls
die die gesellschaftliche integration
auch dass man selber etwas für sich
arbeiten kann dass man selber etwas
verdienen kann und was man dann eben
wirklich ein bisschen stärker wieder wie
darauf sich danach orientieren dass
menschen mit behinderungen unserer
gesellschaft auch etwas wert sein müssen
wo fühlen sie sich persönlich noch am
stärksten eingeschränkt das geht dann
wieder in dem bereich den wir heute
abend auch schon gehört haben wenn man
immer wieder von neuem sachen dagegen
muten fast erklärungen bringen
manchmal habe ich das gefühl aber ich
wehre mich wirklich konsequent dagegen
dass ich mich noch fast entschuldigen
musste dafür dass ich behindert bin eine
das kann es ja nicht sein und ich
versuche dann aber wirklich den menschen
auch offen das seid doch mutiger ich
verstehe zum beispiel sagt das auch
bewusst heute abend hier verstehe nicht
warum das schweizer fernsehen sich so
schwer mit dem thema behinderung zu eine
solche sendung wie sie heute hier
aufgezeichnet wird die müsste doch hätte
doch schon längst passieren müssen hatte
das sind im jahr 2008 sind das thema ist
nicht ein neues abreden ist die frage
wie können
auch wir als betroffene uns in diesem
prozess einbringen es geht dabei nicht
darum dass wir uns da stellen wir sind
keine selbstdarsteller sondern sie wir
sind menschen die in unserer
gesellschaft ihren platz haben nicht
berechtigung sondern ihren platz haben
und diesen platz wussten wir selber aber
auch ausfüllen mit unserem engagement
mit unserer bereitschaft und zu öffnen
auch für andere menschen
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für dieses
kurze gespräch noch zum schluss landen
haben folie anzeige geben gesagt möchten
unbedingt über diesen graubereich
sprechen den herr nationalrat lohr
vorhin angesprochen hat was interessiert
sie im graubereich
ich wollte zunächst mal was anderes
nochmal setzen und zwar finde ich es
fantastisch dass wir eigentlich nicht
überhaupt versprechen
ich bin zwar deswegen eingeladen worden
weil ich diese buch darüber geschrieben
habe aber ich finde es fantastisch dass
hier eigentlich nicht die von die rede
ist meine these ist nämlich dass viel
weniger menschen sich als opfer selber
bezeichnen als in der mittlerweile in
den medien oft irgendwie hat gibt immer
den vorwurf alle würden sich als opfer
mit zeigen ich halte es für für einen
mythos der die welt gesetzt wird alles
andere als das ist der fall gibt immer
solche leute das machen aber ich kann
das nirgendwo finden das wollte ich
jetzt erstmal irgendwie deutlich machen
und diesen graubereich beziehungsweise
diese unterschiede die hier deutlich
werden wie finde ich eigentlich noch mal
sehr sehr wichtig das eigentlich auch zu
tun
sie haben gesagt gerade das als mensch
mit körperlichen behinderung das ja auch
wichtig sein kann diesen ja auch in der
arbeitswelt etwas zu leisten dass das so
viel dass für das selbstwertgefühl ganz
wichtig sein kann
nun ist leistung nicht weit weg von
optimierung oft leistung ist glaube ich
eigentlich ein wichtiges stichwort was
von vielen menschen gesetzt wird als ein
wert der wichtig ist aber ich glaube wir
müssen dann viel differenzierter darüber
sprechen welche art von leistung meinen
und für wen gilt eigentlich was als
leistung
es kann gar nicht jeder oder menschen
mit unterschiedlichen formen von
einschränkungen können unterschiedliche
arten von leistungen bringen aber da
gibt es nicht die leistung und nicht mal
nur die leistung im arbeitsbereich ich
glaube da müsste man noch viel
differenzierter werden und eine eine ja
ich weiß es nicht schön fände ich
eigentlich wenn die nächste sendung die
sie machen noch weiter gehen würde und
nicht eine grenzziehung machen würde die
es hier im augenblick in dieser sendung
gibt es ist nämlich wirklich die grenze
zwischen es gibt menschen mit
körperlichen einschränkungen oder
behinderungen oder psychischen genau
darüber hatten natürlich auch ganz lange
diskutiert und das könnte man auch
machen aber etwas was uns tatsächlich am
herzen gelegen ist und wir kommen
langsam zum ende der sendung und
deswegen bin ich auch so interessiert
daran vielleicht noch herauszufinden wie
denkt man dann über diese
unterschiedlichen kategorien nach und
wie hätte man vielleicht noch besser
darüber nachdenken können etwas was wir
nicht tun wollten ist eben eine grenze
setzen zwischen behindert und nicht
behindert war dann immer so tun als
wären das empirische daten sondern wie
sie ja auch immer wieder betonen und die
ganz viele inklusions organisationen
betonen entscheidet ja auch die
gesellschaft was behindert ist und was
nicht wie wir eben die gesellschaft
einrichten dass menschen zugang haben
oder keinen zugang haben sondern wir
wollten eben die unterschiedlichen
formen von nicht normal von auffallen
thematisieren also solche wie sie die
dick sind menschen die sich verändern
drag queen eine körperkünstlerin ein
mensch der einen unfall erlitten hat und
so weiter
finden sie dass auch problematisch oder
nicht wirklich gelungen
also dafür bin ich glaube ich im
schaffensprozess rund auf sendung
denn nicht der einzige der das
beurteilen kann ob das gelungen ist oder
nicht
ich bin auch die zuschauer in der
sendung das heißt werden dann besser auf
den teilschuld also ich würde sagen es
war eine gute sendung also ich kann es
auch gerade jetzt wo in der im letzten
drittel sind wir glaube ich thematisch
er wirklich ein sehr spannende sachen
gekommen ich finde den genannten super
spannend dass wir wenn wir über das
thema behinderung sprechen oder anders
sein wir eigentlich immer nur diesen
roten faden verschiedene anstatt ihn
abzuschaffen
also zu sagen okay es gibt die
körperbehinderten dass ich jetzt
plötzlich okay ja weil da kann man
aufzubauen aber bei psychischen
erkrankungen
da sind wir uns unsicher aber
letztendlich es ist dann vielleicht doch
wenn wir inklusion ernst meinen noch ein
ganz ganz weiter weg nämlich die
einnahme und die bewältigung von
menschlicher vielfalt das geht sogar
noch weiter und zwar zu sagen nicht die
menschen einem system oder einer
gesellschaft anzupassen sondern die
gesellschaft den menschen und das
bedeutet zu akzeptieren dass jeder
anders ist jeder ist anders und wir aber
im moment ist inklusions begriff fast
schon missbrauchen und die luther und
anwenden auf jene menschen die
volkswirtschaftlich nutzbar sind
ja also wir dann sagen die daneben
arbeiten und leisten können und dabei
vernachlässigen geeilt jene menschen die
dich arbeiten können oder nicht arbeiten
wollen aber die haben genauso ein recht
auf sein auf leben und das müssen wir
glaube ich noch tiefer denken um den
letzten der glaube ich schließen und
wieder alle zusammen persönlich menschen
mit behinderung sind die am schnellsten
wachsende minderheit weltweit weil wir
immer mehr alte menschen haben weil
menschen mit behinderung älter werden
aufgrund der medizinischen besseren
medizinischen versorgung und sie in
allen kulturen existieren ja und wenn
wir irgendwann an den punkt kommen als
gesellschaft zu verstehen dass auch
nicht behinderte menschen ein recht
darauf haben mit menschen mit
behinderung zu
zu leben dann wird es auf einmal 1 1 ein
recht für alle und nicht nur ein recht
für diese zehn prozent das ist ganz ganz
wichtig gedanken lassen sie mich
vielleicht gegen schluss sind noch
einmal zu herrn scherer kommen und
seiner these der avantgarde das
eigentlich das kratzen an der normalität
auch immer sowas avantgardistisches
hatte und das spürt man ja auch wie für
sie da auch sozusagen die kunst dann
sozusagen ihren platz findet avantgarde
und kunst waren immer sehr sehr nah
beieinander was wird denn die avantgarde
sein in zukunft
dann würde ich mich anschließen die
avantgarde wird tatsächlich eine art der
vielfalt seien also gerade wenn ihr
wieder aufs bodybuilding schauen dann
können wir sehen wie es sich entwickelt
hat in den letzten jahrzehnten am anfang
ging es im bodybuilding möglich um eine
ganz klare normen des körpers das war
der unverletzte körper der perfekte
körper die eigentlich über die zeiten
erhabene körper wo aber gleichzeitig man
sagen muss bereits um 14 55 40er 50er
jahren waren im bodybuilding schwarze
körper weiße körper hat man nicht
zwischen unterschieden die konten mister
olympia werden müsste universum werden
und so weiter aber es gab dieses ideal
des unversehrten körpers mittlerweile
gibt es wild cherry bodybuilding
mittlerweile werden im bodybuilding
tattoos akzeptiert es war anfangs nicht
so also ein tattoo das war eine
beeinträchtigung des körperlichen
ästhetische beeinträchtigung
das heißt da öffnet sich das feld dafür
wird genau diese pluralisierung stadt
gleichwohl es gibt noch einen starken
hang zum konservatismus
es gibt im bodybuilding es gibt keine da
klasse im bodybuilding ist es gibt
keinen sozialismus klasse oder keine
kubismus classic bodybuilding das aber
nicht eingeführt wenn irgendwann alles
geht und sie sagen avantgarde bringt uns
immer auch weiter müsste man dann nicht
fast froh sein dass es noch konservative
gibt damit noch platz gibt für avangard
ja absolut dass er die avantgarde ist
immer auf eine form von mainstream
angewiesen das heißt es in dialekt
ischer prozess wenn sich irgendwann
herauskristallisiert weil sie eine
größtmögliche vielfalt die auch
repräsentiert ist in der höhe
sich kite dann hört dass wir das erleben
wir heute schon wieder einig bei
precious geben dann wird das was sie
gegen bewegungen geben dazu was wir
jetzt eben überall an dieser aufgabe
sehen leute die sagen dann wir wollen
zurück zu einer form von homogenität
normalität
das ist eigentlich die gegenbewegung zu
dieser große homogenität der vielfalt
von manchen tagen aufgebracht wird
also ich glaube das wird immer wieder
passieren allerdings sieht man durch die
gesamte geschichte der moderne werden
vielleicht zustimmen immer dann wenn
homogenität auf eine eine oder andere
art und weise erreicht war hat man mit
vielfalt darauf reagiert also die
moderne wirtschaft industrialisierung
hat zu einer pluralisierung der
lebensstile geführt die globalisierung
die wir heute erleben wird auch zu einer
pluralisierung der lebensstile der
ausdrucksformen der existenz formen
führen auch wenn es gleich es gibt
dieser dialektische prozess wird sich
fortsetzen den seen der eben in der
körperkultur es wurde vorher sie haben
es gesagt hat ganz praktisch es gibt
eine größe pluralität wegen der
körperlichen ausdrucks heute als jemals
zuvor auch selbst wenn er nicht immer
verwirklicht wird es gibt die
möglichkeit dazu es gibt es potenzial
ich glaube wir sind tatsächlich jetzt an
einem wunderbaren punkt um hier zu
schließen es gibt viel was ihr nicht
diskutiert haben ich habe sie ganz am
anfang gefragt hackhausen
was muss passieren dass das hier keine
alibi übung wird ich war jetzt fast dich
zu fragen ob seine geworden ist ich tue
es trotzdem weil es mir wirklich auch
wichtig war die frage ernst gemeint zu
haben und sie weiter ernst zu meinen
also nein das war gegen die verbindlich
die weiß wie einige talkshows wie ich
sonst besucht und erlebt habe
ich fand es schön wenn sich das thema
eben jetzt nicht so als einmaliges thema
auf alle bieten alibi thema daher hält
wie ja bereits erwähnt wurde sondern
dass wir das eben auch ein leben im
weitere themen
also ich weiß nicht was die themen der
nächsten sendung sind aber auch da
werden sie es bestimmt darauf achten
dass es nicht nur männer sind sondern
eben auch frauen sie als protagonistin
finden und da aber eben dieses schiff
als merkmal zu erweitern und dann eben
zu sagen okay wir vielleicht eine kleine
frau oder kleinmann oder da denn auch
dort die vielfalt zu leben
ich danke ihm sehr dass sie hier waren
ich bin selber wirklich richtig berührt
und bedanke mich einfach sehr vielen
dank herr krauthausen frau goltermann
harrison hersteller
danke
ja und da von einer sage vielen treffen
dann genau hier im saal und natürlich
auch ihnen zu hause für das interesse an
der diskussion über die normalität und
über vielfalt jetzt gleich gehts weiter
mit einem spielfilm und zwar mit der
entdeckung der unendlichkeit über das
leben des weltbekannten physiker stephen
hawking und das schlusswort übergebe ich
jetzt an pedro lenz ist wird die weko
abgelehnt aber mit ihm bin ich ja dass
sie es gleich bewertet mit jeder fall
muss sie bis negativ ist lang sie zum
beispiel dass weder der make.tv
bewundere den anstieg der bienen zeitig
mit den exklusiven die frage sieht
wirklich 21 24 12 12 über 220 2 vl
hans-peter esch doch überzeugte durch
recht kam nur dank fast opfer töten hat
sich schon eingestellt haben
roland otto bietet größe und wie machen
das mit dem beta des extra großes bett
und mm extra low machen tatsächlich
überzeugte also dass es über 20
das hat jetzt gleich ne tankt mccartney
darin dass es mehr als zwei spiele der
basketball haben
die weiter vorhaben beteiligen sich aber
sicher oder basketball wurde oder für
die sgo genau die waren für die 2 das
sah genau ist es ganz genau umgekehrt
hat mit profi klinik st
die zitierung 150 m achter sogar um 50
bis 85 km eingeschobenen ordnete für
morgen wird es mit dem beta macht
hungrig
also dass er so genau ob sie das jetzt
dank seines kanada immerhin etwas
weniger spiele der minigolf hätte das
motto der beteiligung als sie sich drei
beim minigolf oder zum pony
der morgen war eine technische panne
worum sie minütige blüten der
ruhrpottler also die fliehen alle die
langener ob man nicht in ruhe was ist es
jeden tag mehrmals single heavy cross
dass man ist jeder in zu tag vom
erwachsenen alle die genau gleiche frage
beantworten oder jeden tag vom
erwachsenen gehöre zur sich aber gleich
merken dass man gestartet
man konnte schon mit europäischem
mitstreiter der gartengeräte spätes
komisch gezeigt die bonitätswächter
zwischen
[Applaus]